what
question do you get the most at a bar
like uh we were talking to stone cold
steve austin and people like he's like
people always want to come up to me and
arm wrestle or i think michael bisbee
said like
you know do people come up to you and
like i'll always ask you to do something
to them at a bar when you're drinking
out in public they always ask
me will you kick me in the nuts
everybody wants
yeah everybody wants me to kick them in
the nuts
i i i i can't understand why there's a
guy that i remember
and by the way before if i if i may
you know you almost killed me one time
you you guys with that
the jackass you i was eating a pizza
like
many years ago when i was watching your
movie and i remember you were uh
i don't know if it was you you were
wearing a jack strap and
some alligator was trying yeah
that was me dude
was eating a pizza while i was watching
it and i almost
got a stroke because you make me laugh
so much i almost died man
i'm sorry that that happened
yeah wow you almost killed me like
literally
literally and who who's who's the one
who fought butterbean
is that that's johnny knoxville johnny
knoxville
yeah just snoring yeah snoring
that was bad dude what's wrong with man
my brain
what was the question that you just
asked what question does he get the most
oh yeah what questions you get the most
well what do people do do people ask you
to choke me out
no what they do ask me is they come for
example
one or two guys and they ask me is hey
how long you think we could hang
with you and like how long we would last
against you and i don't know i tell them
i'm like well i i
you know it's a i can't answer that
question and they they say
approximately and i ask them i say it
depends
do you carry a gun do you have any
weapons they say no say do you run
fast i'm like yeah maybe you wouldn't
last very long
that's a good answer you mean you mean
hanging out with you like in a fight
yeah how long can we last fighting you
yeah how long would you last into a
fight like if i decide to
to beat them up how long they will how
long they could be able to stand you
know
it's always it always depends on every
individual right
yeah well that's like uh when brendan
shaw was talking about you know
jon jones being the goat they're like
he's like he can take out like 10 guys
in a bar
and then i asked him you know how many
how many guys can uh izzy out of sonia
take out he's like he can probably do
like eight just because of his size
how many dudes at a bar do you think you
can [ __ ] up before
you get taken over average guys but it's
always
it always depends which kind of guy you
know like small guy guys he knows how to
fight
guys who has weapon and in it i was
i was a doorman in a bar and i'm gonna
tell you something
we talk about street fight and mma fight
this is these are two different things
like very different things i remember
some time like even
women were very hard to deal with
because a woman you know in a street
fight like she's gonna grab a bottle and
a woman can hurt you just as bad as a
man you know like like
and in a street there's no rules
so the the fact that you're a champion
in mixed martial
arts it's not a a a hundred percent
uh like guarantee that you will win the
fight you know what i mean
anybody can come behind me tap me on the
shoulder and
if i don't expect it throw a big punch
and knock me out cold like every what
you don't see coming is what
that's what knocked you out everybody
can do it to me i mean i mean
to a certain extent but what i'm saying
is in a street fight
the element of surprise is the most
important thing
and i was bullied a lot when i was young
and
one thing that i had to my own my
advantage is
that because i was a nice guy i was
never looking for trouble i had the
limit of surprise because before that
the fight
happened there's no referee that say go
there's something that
that needs to to happen there's a
someone that instigate the fight
and when you feel the heat rising too
much
now you because you're the nice guy
you're on the defense he's the one
looking for trouble
you have the element of surprise and
that gives you a big edge
it's it's like a head start and if you
know how to fight on top of that
it's your chance of winning are like
almost a
99.9 wow so always throw the first punch
always be the never be the aggressor
always be the one
who's uh i mean that's why to be a nice
guy to be
to not look for trouble in a way
if you don't look for trouble and you
know how to fight you have a big
big advantage over anybody who comes
to look for trouble with you because you
have the element of surprise
i'm not talking about someone who does
not know how to fight of course if you
don't know how to fight
you know you don't know how to deal with
this situation but if you do know how to
fight
man it's a it's a huge huge huge
advantage
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude